all right
kiera yeah or also known as kelly on my
channel
yeah um that was your that was your
street name that you asked me to use
yeah back then but a lot has gone on
since you and i spoke
almost a year ago yeah that was
christmas eve that you and i met
mm-hmm uh so first before we even get
into what's going on
in your life today
let's let's address what there was this
kind of
i don't know what they call it but a lot
of people claimed your story was untrue
and and i i have my ideas as to why that
happened
what are your thoughts on it honestly
i just think people
they don't know so or i don't honestly
they think that i did it for money well
i didn't do it for the money because you
didn't know that there was a gofundme
right connected to your campaign that
was something i did and
didn't tell anyone you didn't know but
people don't know that so they assumed
that you know
that i did it for you it was actually i
told you when it was twelve thousand
dollars and you told me to stop it at 12
at 13 000 i think yeah which i didn't do
i let it go to 28 28.
in two days it went up to 28 000. and
then i stopped it
it went up it went up really fast so of
course people thought i did it for money
and for clout
but i don't care i don't let things like
that face me because i know what i've
been through you know
yeah i learned a lot from social media
through you yeah
because i was ready to let's do a video
and show the scars in front of your ears
let's show them your foster pa you know
the paperwork showing your foster
system history and show them this that
and the other and
you you said no don't do a thing just
let it go
haters are gonna because i knew it would
like die down and then we have i have
more
believers than you know accusers so it's
just like
i don't care i know my truth i know what
i've been through so you know i don't
i'm not going to let people that don't
even know me you know
here's a couple things to consider if
anyone is doubting your story
if you had a tight relationship with
your so apparently there were pictures
of you and your
mom or your grandmom on on uh and me and
my friends
your mom is still alive right so you can
get together for the holidays and take
pictures
for the holidays that's what people do
yeah that's why
they're posted they those are times that
obviously meant
something you know but if you were if
you if you had a tight relationship with
your
family why would you be spending
christmas with a white dude that you met
the day before
why would i i didn't spend my christmas
with anyone but my boyfriend
why would you why would you be living on
the street in a tent for a month for a
month you were
and then people doing that two months
maybe yeah i don't know
people whatever there's a washington
post article i'll leave in the link of
the description people can read it and
see that
your story is true except you got the
year of your foster system
wrong you were you said it was six and
it was five or vice versa i'm not sure
what
but i was young at that age yeah you
know so of course i'm just
waiting for what i've been through so
let's let's move on
yeah yeah i i love the way you handled
it though that was that was
i learned a lot from that um so
you got 28 000 bit by bit for through
the gofundme
i'm sure you appreciate all the donors
there hopefully i appreciate that thank
you to everyone that supported
thank you to all the ones that actually
believe my story you know the ones that
are actually genuine
i appreciate it it really helped me out
i was able to get
an apartment i was able to get a car you
know
really helped me get get on my feet yeah
and you've done a great job since then
as we'll get into
uh you're now living in an apartment far
from south central l.a far from skid row
yeah in a neighborhood that's very safe
and it'll be a year that i've been
living there
too in february so yeah no you're doing
a great job i i
you and i speak almost every at least
once or twice a week now
every week and i see what you're doing i
see how hard you're working
you've had three jobs since since this
all happened yeah
we helped you get off the street the
donors did and myself and we
got you into a great situation i'm sorry
i said of course you too
yeah so much i do people always ask me
does mark help you does hey does that
guy help you i'm always like
yeah like he helps me a lot a lot
yeah but i don't want this to be about i
don't want this to turn into a help chat
of course
but yeah so i i tend to not show that i
don't want to show that stuff
so but i do help people um but
you've had you got one job and then
kovid came and you lost that job because
they closed the stores you were working
in
you got another job and then the same
thing happened again and today you're
working as what
um a caregiver for the elderly for like
uh
alzheimer's patients and things like
that dementia you know bedridden peop
um people all different types of you
know
i don't know all of the terms yet
because i'm still in training
you know i still have to obtain those
certificates and things like that so i'm
going to those classes today
you're working six days a week yeah six
days a week i'm tired
you're tired today because you were just
yeah i'm tired it's my off day i'm tired
yeah but so you know because i've
interviewed
i think i counted it yesterday i've
interviewed like
over 200 women that work the streets
mostly on figaro street
and uh what
do you what what what what got you out i
mean you you're very different than all
the other girls who are still working
the street
they haven't broken free of that
lifestyle and you were determined to do
it
honestly i think for me it's because i
didn't
i didn't want to be in that lifestyle
you know like that wasn't something that
i wanted to continue doing you know i
felt the pain of that lifestyle you know
i felt the struggle of that lifestyle
so it's like you know i didn't want to
do that anymore i wanted to change you
know i watch
tv or i watch social media you know
and i see different things that i want
to you know you know obtain
i want to be in life so you know i just
pretty much
didn't want to do that anymore so that's
why
i stopped and i came down here you know
i ran away from
you you know my that my at last guy
and you know i came down here to
get away and i was i met you
and now i'm here you know thank god so
i think it was just pretty much me not
wanting to be down there and then on top
of that
you know i um
i'm like in my head i'm headstrong
you are very headstrong yeah and i think
that's the real key to
what helped you be so focused and
determined
from breaking out because everyone all
the other girls that i've spoken to
and then i think reading books too yeah
you read a lot
but but a lot of the girls that i've
interviewed that that worked the streets
mostly on figueroa um have very very
similar stories to yours
yeah i would imagine and their stories
you know the dates are a little
different the views was slightly
different but basically a very similar
story to yours
they started at a very young age and so
on yeah but they're still doing it and
you're
you are so kind of focused and
determined and hard-headed in a way in a
good way
yeah of making a decision and sticking
to it
because i know there were times when um
because we had problems with gofundme
because of all the
all the all the claims that you're lying
yeah gofundme wouldn't release the money
for a long time so so i had to keep
supporting you but
it got really awkward at one point where
i was like man i'm just bleeding money
yeah
and there was no sign that gofundme was
going to cooperate right
and all the negativity that you were
getting made go fund me go well i don't
think
i think this is a scam yeah because
everyone was saying it was a scam but uh
i honestly you know what my other
thought that i didn't say earlier
all the reaction to your video not being
true i i almost think when some when
viewers
and some viewers and you got to
understand it's a very small percentage
yeah but when some viewers watch a video
like yours where here's somebody who is
fighting adversity and doing the right
thing for themselves and that can be
getting off the streets as you did
stopping using drugs as you did but it
could also be
you know all the problems people have in
relationships and putting up with
with with less than you know and they
see
what they're not doing in your video if
you're doing what they should be doing
yeah and rather than deal with that they
lash out at you and try to knock you
down
and i think that might have been the the
real thing that was going on with your
video because
i thought of that too because your story
is no different than anyone else's
something similar to that i thought but
you got the gofundme and they saw you
doing the right thing and it's like the
whole thing just made everyone go
let's knock her down yeah i think there
was a lot of that because some people
made like they may look at the video and
they're probably like wow i just can't
imagine
this girl going through all of those
things so they you know they don't
believe it or
some people may not be happy with
themselves you know so
they may not believe me but honestly i
don't
dwell i never dwelled on the people that
didn't believe me
i never no you never did i never cared
about the people that didn't believe me
you know i only care and i only respond
to people
that are you know supporters or that are
being genuine
you know you i'll never really know
who's really being genuine but
if you're portraying yourself to be
genuine and you're being kind and you're
coming to me with respect then of course
you know
if i see you know i'll i'll definitely
shop
reach back out and say thank you and
what i appreciate
you know i don't i've never dwelled on
the negative comments your story is also
so heartbreaking it's it's hard for some
people to deal with
right you had nothing nobody's helping
you in any way and it's like you
persevered and were unwilling to
compromise
yeah and that's almost what i think the
quality that you possess that really
helped you break free
because now you're living a very very
different life than you did before
and i had support you know i was in a
low space i was suicidal
i was a lot but i came through with you
know
meeting you you know and stuff like that
boyfriend yeah and um
so i'm just very proud of you i think i
think you're
you have all the tools to thrive in life
you just needed a little
head start with the which is what we
gave you so
what what do you think helped you the
most i mean i i think it's your your
personality of being very hard-nosed and
helped me the most with what just
getting your life straight
because so many people can't and don't i
think
i think my mindset and like you said my
personality
um my mind's really more so my mindset
i will see things that i want things
that i want to do
you know it's not fun being out on the
street all day you know selling your
body that's not
some it's not it's degrading it gets
tiring it gets painful
so you know of course as a young a woman
well any young woman in her right mind
is going to think hey i don't want to do
this well you should
you know i feel like that's not
something that you just
but there's a difference some girls they
enjoy doing that you know it's fun to
them it was never fun to me
so you know but what advice would you
give to a young woman who's
considering doing something like this i
definitely don't do it you know
it's degrading you know um
it's degrading to yourself at a it comes
to a point where it's degrading to
yourself
and then um you know you're just better
than that i definitely don't want to
sell your body you're better than that
there's plenty of other things that you
can do
to you know get what you need get the
support you need you know
definitely don't need to do that i just
i just wouldn't
i just wouldn't i would never tell a
young
woman or a girl to to sell her body i
would i would never
what are the positives and negatives of
because there are there are some
positives to that that lifestyle with a
lot of negatives
what are the how do you compare the like
are you happier today than you were then
definitely i would think so yeah what
are the positives and negatives of each
lifestyle because
you're living a very different life now
the positives of that lifestyle i would
only say it's the fast money
i guess and there's lots of negatives
with it but there's
hell of negatives so out of a hundred
there's
one percent one percent good and then
there's the 99
of that that lifestyle comes with
a lot you know you you get in a car with
someone
and that person you don't know what kind
of tip they're on
but next thing you know you have a gun
to your head you know and you're getting
raped
so it's just like that lifestyle is not
the lifestyle that you want to live it's
not safe
for one it's not safe for your health
it's not safe for
your security and it's it's degrading
so the downside of where you're at today
is maybe you're making a little less
money it's not fast money it's slow
money
it's uncle sam's money
yes he takes a fight but but what are
the upsides of your new life
um i'm happier i'm in a better space
you know i'm not degrading myself
the moves that i make are based off of
my own mindset
you know i'm just moving with love and
care
i'm in a better space people that are
around me
you know they're they're they're loving
and caring you know
so i'm just i'm just in a better space
i'm working
you know i'm gonna be moving soon
so i'm just happy i'm just building for
my future
it's been beautiful to watch your your
transformation from
a lot of a lot of depression a lot of
stress a lot of negativity and
just difficulty and now you're like much
more positive
and happier and mellow oh my gosh
thank you but literally i don't know why
i just thought about
how people say oh she's lying she has
braces
braces cost four thousand dollars like
what
no they don't my braces are only two
thousand well if you look at the other
videos of all the girls that do that for
a living they
many of them had braces many of them
have very expensive nails or various and
then they act like
there aren't payment plans i pay a
hundred dollars a month for my braces no
no
it's it's not about the the fact that
it's just funny
yeah i know it's it's just funny because
as i was smiling i felt my braces
and then i i know we're doing an
interview so i just thought of that
haters want to hate that's what it's
about i think
yeah what what regrets do you have in
your life
i wouldn't say i have regrets i would
say i have lessons
learned because without without me going
through the things that i went through
and without me you know going through
things
i wouldn't have a i wouldn't have
learned a lesson i wouldn't know not to
do that you know
i wouldn't i wouldn't know oh no don't
do that because this
is going to be the outcome you know so i
just take everything as a lesson i
kind of pretty much try to live with no
regrets
but i i just take everything as a lesson
learned and
if i take a l i eat it i eat it like a
grown woman you know but other than
that i just
i know i've been through some things i
know i've had you know
dirt on my name at a time but because of
that but
other than that i don't really have many
makes you stronger yeah it's what
doesn't kill you makes you stronger
yeah and how's your relationship with
your mom today we're good we're really
good
um you know we talk i
i hit her up every day and stuff like
that so we're great
and what do you i mean the foster system
story you told was horrifying what
what do you think the solution is to
that honestly
i think that the social workers need to
be more active in the
foster children's lives and um
there shouldn't always be meetings like
when the
when the first when the when the social
worker comes
to visit the child there it shouldn't
just be
when if they shouldn't it shouldn't just
be a meeting with the foster parents
the child and the social worker it
should be a point where it's just a
social worker and the child
so the child can feel safe enough to
express themselves
and then on top of that when they do
express themselves then the social
worker knows that it's going to be a
little time frame before something can
be done
they shouldn't um they shouldn't expose
or give a reaction to what the child
just said because it kind of you know
it kind of like tells on what the the
child just says so now
you never know what's going you know i
just feel like it should be
more confidentiality and if i'm saying
that word right
and um did i say it right yeah and
um and i feel like
they should just be more so in their
lives and there should be more visits
it shouldn't just be once a month it
should be probably about
three a month three visits a month
i would say all right kira
thank you so much for coming in again
thank you you didn't want to come in for
a long time because it was just there's
so much like
yeah attention your video got like
almost six million views
i don't i don't want people i don't i
don't need that
you don't need that nobody needs that
yeah it was crazy
yeah probably go viral again uh
no no no it's it's but you're hopefully
this one is
this one's inspirational for the you
know believers
yes yeah you're amazing i'm so proud of
you thank you i appreciate it
so proud of you thank you
you